And now, it is my pleasure to start this morning's scientific
program by introducing the program chairs for the AACR Annual
Meeting 2026.
To address the challenge of developing a program that showcased the breadth and
depth of the field, I called upon two outstanding
scientists whose combined expertise is broad enough to
understand and integrate the full spectrum of cancer science and medicine
into a dynamic meeting. I am very grateful that they agreed to
take on this difficult but very important job.
The first program co-chair is Dr. Paul S. Michiel. Dr.
Michiel is the Fortinet Founders Professor and Vice Chair for
Research in the Department of Pathology at Stanford Medicine, as
well as an institute scholar and deputy director of Translational
Science at Sarphan ChEM-H at Stanford University.
His research has led to a series of seminal discoveries that have
identified a central role for extrachromosomal DNA in cancer
development, progression, accelerated tumor evolution, and
drug resistance. These findings have launched a new area of cancer
research that links circular architecture with tumor
pathogenesis. Paul is a member of the National Academy of
Medicine and an elected fellow and past president of the American
Society for Clinical Investigation.
He was inducted as a fellow of the AACR Academy in
2025. Joining Dr. Paul Michiel as the
program chair is Dr. Alice T. Shaw.
Alice is chair of the Department of Medical Oncology and chief of
Strategic Partnerships at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
She is also the George P. and Jeanne S.
Kanellos Professor of Medicine at Harvard Medical School.
Alice is a basic science-trained physician and translational
researcher, whose work centers on the intersection of clinical
oncology and molecular genetics, with a particular focus
on oncogene-driven lung cancers.
She leads a team conducting groundbreaking translational and clinical
research, while also providing exceptional clinical care.
In her role as chief of strategic partnerships, she oversees the
collaborative efforts between researchers and the life sciences
industry to help accelerate the development of innovative new
therapies for patients with cancer.
Alice is concluding her term as a member of the AACR Board of Directors,
and on Friday, she was inducted as a fellow of the AACR Academy.
This meeting is the world's foremost cancer research event,
and I'm deeply grateful to Paul and Alice for devoting their time and
expertise to guide the development of this comprehensive
state-of-the-art scientific program.
Please join me in welcoming to the stage the program chairs
of the AACR Annual Meeting 2026, Dr.
Paul Michiel and Dr. Alice Shaw.
Thank you, Lillian, for your kind words.
Alice and I are grateful for this opportunity
to serve as program committee chairs, and we thank you for your
leadership over the past year. It's been a pleasure to work
with you.
And we'd like to welcome all of you to the opening plenary session
of the AACR Annual Meeting 2026.
More than 22,000 of you have gathered here in San
Diego and online to explore and advance the
frontier of cancer science and medicine.
You have submitted more than 7,400 abstracts for
presentation in a wide range of categories, and we
thank you for choosing the AACR Annual Meeting as a presentation
venue for your work.
It's been nearly 18 months since Alice and I accepted Dr.
Su's gracious invitation to serve as program chairs for this meeting,
and the world has certainly changed since then.
Cancer research is under threat. From abrupt and
indiscriminate dismissals of the dedicated public servants at the
NIH, to major cuts to leading research institutions and
cancer centers across the US, to the administration's attempt
to cut the 2026 NIH budget by nearly
40%.
As Alice and I began working with the program committee to plan this meeting
under the shadow of these disruptions, we understood
the extraordinary responsibility and the extraordinary
opportunity that was before us. The AACR
Annual Meeting is the most important cancer research meeting in the world.
And at a time when science is under attack, we knew that both the
cancer community and the public would be looking to this meeting for
inspiration,
and you will find it. Look around. Over
22,000 of us have come together from all over the world with
shared purpose and unshakable commitment to advance
cancer science to save lives globally.
We are in it together. The annual meeting will
showcase and integrate unprecedented advances in basic,
translational, clinical, and population science over the past
year and how these advances are already changing the
lives of people with cancer. Together, we are
shaping the future of cancer.
Thank you, Paul. And I couldn't agree more.
Cancer research saves lives. With this front and center,
the theme that Paul, Lillian, and I developed for this meeting
is Precision. Partnership. Purpose.
Advancing cancer science to save lives globally.
Our goal is to demonstrate how cutting-edge science
conducted in a spirit of collaboration drives meaningful
progress and ensures that all patients around the
world enjoy the benefits of that progress.
As you will see this week, the program has been designed with this
purpose in mind.
First, we have placed a greater emphasis on organ site
sessions that illuminate advances against specific types of
cancer with still high unmet need.
In addition, the program features a robust survivorship track
that highlights improvements in clinical care and quality of life
for those living with cancer.
Most importantly, the daily plenary sessions will showcase
how the cancer community is delivering on the promise of
cancer research, including innovative modalities that could
change the future of cancer therapy, breakthroughs in the
prevention, detection, and treatment of early-onset cancers,
and a survey of the ways in which AI, artificial intelligence,
is transforming the field.
We're very proud to share this program with you, and we're grateful to the
38 co-chairs of the Scientific Program Committee,
the 267 program subcommittee members who
reviewed all of the abstracts,
the 44 co-chairs and members of the Clinical Trials Committee,
and the 19 co-chairs and members of the Education
Committee for their hard work and expert guidance in developing this
meeting over the past year.
We hope that this opening plenary session will inspire you to spend
the next four days exploring new approaches, forming
new connections and collaborations, and renewing your
commitment to our shared purpose to cure and prevent all
cancers.
And now, it is my pleasure to introduce to you the
first speaker of the opening plenary session, Dr. Charles L.
Sawyers. Dr. Sawyers is the Marie-Josée and
Henry R. Kravis Chair in Human Oncology and Pathogenesis,
and the Chair of the Human Oncology and Pathogenesis Program at
Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
A fellow of the AACR Academy and a former president of the
AACR, Dr. Sawyers is a physician
scientist and leader in the development of molecular targeted
therapies for cancer. His laboratory has identified
cell signaling components critical to the growth of cancer cells in
chronic myeloid leukemia, prostate, and other cancers,
resulting in the development of multiple
FDA-approved inhibitors in clinical trials.
Most notably, he and his colleagues played a critical role in
developing the molecularly targeted cancer drug Gleevec for the
treatment of chronic myeloid leukemia. Today, Dr.
Sawyers will discuss his work in a presentation titled "How Cancer
Cells Escape Targeted Therapy by Changing Identity."
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Sawyers.
Thank you, Paul. Thank you, Alice.
It's a great honor for me to be asked to give this talk.
As you just heard, I'm a past president.
I love the AACR, and I love seeing all of you here today.
So we're going to move straight into science.
And I'm starting with this slide that I
showed in 2002 at the New Orleans meeting when
I gave an education session. And the point of this slide is to
describe a phenomenon that I've seen over the last 25 years, sort of
being in the front row of the development of many targeted agents.
And that is,
if we understand the biology of the tumor and know what the driver is, and have the
fortune to have a pharmacological strategy to inhibit, we get great
responses.
But we
realize that there's the problem of acquired resistance.
And in the first many years of developing these
different targeted therapies, the resistance
mechanisms were worked out one by one, and they are
mutations, amplifications, bypass pathways, et cetera.
But as that then informed
more intelligent ways of coming up with next gen therapies, we started to
see a change to different mechanisms of resistance, which we call
off-target. And I've summarized this here, again, from the
closing slide from four years ago, that I felt that
we sort of learned the rules for on-target resistance.
We know how to make better inhibitors, but as we put more and more selective
pressure on that initial driver, we start seeing new escape
mechanisms. And this is something that is now a new challenge, and
I concluded with the statement that we should be able to beat
lineage plasticity if we can understand the molecular underpinnings.
So my task today is to report back to you, four years later, on what we've learned.
And the disease that I'm going to discuss this in is in prostate cancer.
But I think our findings are quite relevant to other
epithelial tumors.
So when I first started working deeply in prostate cancer,
the question was: What is the cause of acquired resistance to first generation
hormone therapy? These are drugs that lower systemic androgen levels
as well as antagonists that competitively inhibit binding of
testosterone to the androgen receptor.
And what we and others found over a series of years is something
that now, in the light of what I just showed you, was probably sort
of staring us in the face, and that is, it's the target.And
its changes in androgen receptor expression levels through amplification,
splice variants, mutations, etc.
That work or that finding in my case sparked a collaboration with Dr.
Michael Jung to develop a next generation anti-androgen.
And what came out of that work is a drug called enzalutamide that's now been on
the market since 2012
and has proven to be quite effective in men with castration-resistant prostate
cancer. I had no role in the clinical development of the drug, but I was very
pleased to open up an issue of New England Journal a couple of years ago
to see this randomized Phase III trial in men who are early
in prostate cancer relapse. They have what's called biochemical relapse.
And you can see from the Kaplan-Meier curve that there's quite a significant
survival advantage in men who receive the androgen-lowering drug plus
enzalutamide. So men are living longer,
tens of thousands of men benefiting around the world.
But
it's still not a cure, so what's the next challenge?
So I go back to this cartoon and now show you that this
simple diagram of where adenocarcinoma would progress through increased
androgen receptor activity to a resistant
adenocarcinoma. We're starting to see new
patterns of resistance where the histology of the tumor in its most
extreme form can undergo a complete lineage switch from an
adenocarcinoma to a neuroendocrine cancer that looks for all
the world like small cell lung cancer.
And indeed, the transcription factors that these tumors express are
sort of a dead match for those that are seen in different subtypes of small
cell lung cancer. So for the rest of the talk, I'm going to tell you how
we've tried to understand how this process happens, with the idea
that if we can
do that, maybe we can get a toehold into how to stop this or prevent
it. And in order to tackle this question scientifically, it
was critical to have models in the laboratory in which we could
watch the transition occur
in a reasonable period of time and then have the ability to perturb that
system to identify vulnerabilities.
So the first success in that came from taking advantage
of the tumor suppressor genes
that are mutated in these different states.
What we know from tumor genome sequencing is that PTEN and
p53 loss of function mutations are seen in about 50% of
men with castration-resistant prostate cancer, but they tend to segregate
across all of these different subtypes.
Whereas loss of RB, the RB tumor suppressor gene
is found in about 20 or 30% of cases and it seems to
be tightly correlated with the appearance of this neuroendocrine
histology.
So taking advantage of those tumor suppressor gene insights,
David Goodrich from Roswell Park
crossed mice with floxed alleles of these different tumor suppressors in
various combinations and then did a prostate-specific deletion.
And what he found is that when he deleted RB in combination with either of
the other two suppressors or all three together, he got an
adenocarcinoma that transitioned to a neuroendocrine cancer.
We teamed up with David to do single-cell RNA sequencing of a time course
of these mice. And what we saw on the right was the
appearance of the adenocarcinoma cells. All the tumor cells are marked in red.
And then subsequently, the emergence of the neuroendocrine tumor that we had seen
histologically. But what we also saw were the appearance of other
subpopulations that are clearly different lineages that
had been missed histologically, but clearly appear in the mice.
This one is of some interest. It's defined by a transcription factor known as
POW2F3 that remarkably defines a subset of small cell lung
cancer well-recognized, as well as mesenchymal tumors.
But those of you who do mouse genetics will know that if you just look at
this
triple cross mouse, this is
a total of seven alleles to generate one experiment, and additional
perturbations would require not only money, time, mouse
cages, etc. We needed a new system to move more quickly.
So Rodrigo Romero in my lab developed that system.
What he did was to take advantage of our expertise in
isolating normal prostate tissue from a mouse and being able to grow it in culture
and retain all the cell types that are present in vivo.
And then he developed very efficient ways of genomically
perturbing them using CRISPR as well as lentiviral
infections to create, if you will, a sort of genetic menu of
choice. When he combined RB and
p53 and overexpression of MYC, another
common finding in advanced prostate cancer, he
got a beautiful model that replicated what we had seen in the genetically
engineered mice, and that is an adenocarcinoma that transitions to a
neuroendocrine cancer with lymph node metastases and lung
metastases. And this is now in a matter of weeks instead of years.
So the next question is what are the sort of triggers that
cause this transition?
And I should mention in order to see this transition,
Rodrigo had to put the cells into the mouse.
If he maintained them in organoid culture, they would stay in the
adenocarcinoma fate. So
what Teng Han in the lab noticed is that there's a rich
stromal proliferation, a CAF population that appears when the
adenocarcinoma is growing in its early stages.
But then when it transitions to the neuroendocrine state, you see this
relative depletion of the fibroblasts.
So since fibroblasts make extracellular matrix and
since
extracellular matrix is a key ingredient in our
organoid culture, Teng had the idea of perhaps
the transition is not occurring in vitro because we've got too much
matrix as in this stateSo to cut to the chase,
he did a very simple experiment, which is to take the organoids out of Matrigel and
grow them in suspension culture.
And it was quite dramatic that
at seven days, he could see a blush of expression of the neuroendocrine
lineage
master regulator ASCL1, which went to much higher levels after two
weeks and stayed that way in continuous culture.
And you can see this at the protein level as well.
You can see ASCL1 positive cells in these organoids that
have a morphologic appearance of adenocarcinoma.
If you keep passaging these organoids, the rest of the organoid doesn't fill
in, so it's this spotty mosaic pattern, which I'll come back to in just a minute.
So putting cells in suspension is a pretty dramatic
stress to put them under. So to get more focused on whether it was
truly extracellular matrix that was the driver of this
change, we looked at integrin signaling.
So the two main ingredients in Matrigel are collagen and laminin, and
they both work through engagement of the integrin receptor, and they share
a common subunit known as beta-1. So what's shown
here on the far right is in organoids grown in
Matrigel, if you delete the ability of the organoids to
recognize the extracellular matrix by deleting the beta-1's common
subunit, you can reproduce what he had seen in suspension culture, which is this
ASCL1 sort of pattern of expression in this
mosaic pattern.
So the next question is: What's downstream?
So what I've shown you so far is extracellular matrix engages the
receptor and is exerting a break or a restraint on the
ability of these RB-deleted cells that want to undergo the lineage
transition, but they're being prevented. So what is it that's doing the preventing?
So you can look at signaling diagrams of integrin engagement
downstream, and there are many pathways.
I think a lot of you are familiar with these.
We looked one by one to try to figure out who's the culprit.
And the culprit turns out to be the pathway involving YAP, TAZ,
and the DNA-binding protein TEAD.
And the way we got there was to take advantage of a
small molecule inhibitor of a kinase known as
LATS-1/2 that had been developed by
Jim Hudspeth's lab across the street at Rockefeller University.
So this pathway between integrin engagement and YAP,
TAZ, and TEAD
is very interesting and well studied in Hippo
signaling.
It's important to realize that it's a series of negative steps.
So in this case, giving the LATS inhibitor blocks the kinase
activity and prevents YAP from being phosphorylated.
An unphosphorylated YAP is the active form.
So to test out whether this tool compound would be useful in our
system, we did this experiment over here where we put the cells in suspension.
They will start to express ASCL1
if we wait long enough,
and we see the loss of
YAP activity because we see loss of expression of a YAP target gene here,
and we see the phosphorylation of YAP by LATS kinase, which
is now on because this negative signal is released,
and we can reverse that with the LATS inhibitor.
But the key experiment was to keep them in suspension long enough for them to
start to go into the neuroendocrine state, so they're expressing lots of ASCL1,
and then add the LATS inhibitor. And what you can see here is we can reverse
that upregulation of ASCL1. So this tells us that
this lineage transition, once it starts to happen, is potentially
reversible pharmacologically, and I'll come back to that.
So here's what the cartoon now looks like.
In the adenocarcinoma state, when there's plenty of extracellular matrix and
stroma, you've got cells that are poised because of RB loss to
undergo the transition, but this is a brake on that system.
But if you remove the matrix, you block the integrin signaling, and as I'll show
you on the next slide, if you interfere specifically with just the
YAP/TEAD interface binding with a small
molecule protein interaction disruptor that's been
developed by Novartis,
you can push these cells all the way to this other state, a neuroendocrine
state that turns on. So here's an example of the TEAD inhibitor.
So here's, again, a series of organoids grown in
standard media where there's no ASCL1.
The TEAD drug does just what I showed you with suspension and integrin receptor
knockout. You see the activation of ASCL1 in a subset of the
cells. And now we've layered on a second pathway, and this is the Notch
pathway, and this inhibition is done using a gamma
secretase inhibitor. And you can see that a subset of cells will also
turn
ASCL1 positive with Notch inhibition.
And we did this experiment because Notch is implicated in small cell lung cancer
transitions. And David Goodrich, who I mentioned earlier, also has some evidence
that it's involved in this transition.
But what I think is really striking is on the far right, and that is when we
combine these two, we solve that problem that I mentioned earlier.
That mosaic pattern now disappears, and we are getting essentially 100% of
the cells turning to ASCL1 positive.
So this now gave us an opportunity to really ask if we
could develop, sort of recreate the entire
adeno to neuroendocrine transition in an organoid cultured in
vitro system.
And in order to ask the next question, we did the following experiment.
So we used the YAP/TEAD inhibitor, we used the Notch
inhibitor, the gamma secretase, and we used enzalutamide to inhibit
all three pathways at once in cells in organoid culture, and then
harvest cells at different times,
after eight days or after 42 days. And we did this as singlets,
doublets, and triple drug therapy.
And we then harvested the cells and performed bulk RNA sequencing and
plotted the data on a principal component analysis. And I'll orient you.
The cells that have no treatment are in DMSO.
Their transcriptome maps on this plot down to the bottom left.
And as a positive control for the neuroendocrine state, we
isolated tumors from mice that had undergone the full neuroendocrine transition,
and that's this cluster of... tumors over
here. And what I hope you can see is that
four to six weeks of continuous treatment with these drugs
is able to move the cells all the way to the fully neuroendocrine
state. We can also confirm that at the protein level by doing
western blots of these in vitro differentiated cells versus the
actual tumors. And you can see we get expression of many of the canonical
neuroendocrine markers, showing that we've faithfully replicated
the system. So now that we have this system, we can start to take apart
the molecular details of what's happening during these early time points
that sets this process underway.
And one of the first experiments we did was to look at the
chromatin binding sites of both YAP and TEAD at the
beginning and at the end. And what you can see is
in the adenocarcinoma state, you see these set of TEAD
binding peaks that overlap very nicely with the YAP binding
peaks, as you would expect, because this is a two protein
heterodimer transcription factor.
And you can see the appearance of the enrichment for TEAD
motifs. But what caught us by complete surprise
is that we see a whole new set of TEAD binding peaks at different
loci in the neuroendocrine state when there's no YAP
and no TAZ.
And this confirms that indeed these are TEAD motifs where
these peaks are binding. And interestingly,
closely associated motif with these new peaks is the
consensus motif for FOXA1, a well-known pioneer
transcription factor, which is expressed in the adenocarcinoma state.
So we then asked what's happening to FOXA1, and FOXA1
is present in the adenocarcinoma state at these peaks and relocalizes
at the same sites as the TEAD binding
peaks in the neuroendocrine state.
And so what we now know is that if we delete FOXA1 in this system, we can
prevent the transition from happening.
So to wrap up this section,
what I've shown you is that there are three signals that
restrain the
ability of RB deleted adenocarcinoma cells to undergo the
transition.
One involving YAP/TEAD activation through integrin signaling, one involving
Notch, we don't know the molecular details, and of course, the androgen
receptor inhibition, which sets off the process in the first
place. Now when we give inhibitors of these
pathways, as I've just shown you, and also add enzalutamide,
we get this transition to occur. And as I was just telling you but
not showing you the primary data, this process, within a matter of
days, leads to the relocalization of FOXA1 to
new places in
closed chromatin that are then opened through its pioneering function
that become the new enhancers for TEAD to bind, to turn on
ASCL1, and to set out a full cascade of lineage transition.
So can we do anything about this therapeutically?
Well, today we cannot, but here's the vision I would like to paint.
So here's the process.
And what I've shown you is there are now three points, YAP/TEAD,
Notch, and androgen receptor, all three of which are pharmacologically
accessible with existing or potentially further
developed molecules. If we wanted to do something clinically, what
I have in mind as a first shot would be something that is going to
sound counterintuitive. As I mentioned,
the Novartis compound that disrupts the YAP/TEAD interaction is
in clinical development at Novartis for other indications,
mesotheliomas, which are dependent upon this pathway as a driver
oncogene. But what I've just described to you is that that
compound, if given to a patient who was in this
lineage transition situation, might be predicted to push the
lineage transition even faster to the neuroendocrine state.
So I mention that as counterintuitive because, of course, that would be a much more
aggressive phase of the disease. But the reason it's worth even talking about
is because there's now an FDA-approved drug
that it can engage the DLL3 cell surface receptor, a direct
downstream target of ASCL1 in these neuroendocrine cells.
It's a T cell engager that's been approved for its
efficacy in small cell lung cancer.
In prostate cancer, it's been tested but has some activity,
but not very compelling, and I think that's because the patients have this mixed
histology, a mix of this and a mix of this, and you see partial
responses.
The alternative, and perhaps more logical approach might be to push
the tumors that are starting to go this way, all the way back to the left, where
we have a plethora of cell surface markers that are well
understood and for which there are therapeutic, either
approved drugs, such as the radioligand therapy
for PSMA, as well as drugs in development, again, T cell
engagers. So
to close this part,
my thinking is that we would take advantage of
this toggle switch to transiently give one of these
inhibitors to push them either to the left or to the right, and then rely
on the immune system drugs, the T cell engagers, CAR Ts that you'll hear
about from Carl and others,
to perhaps come in and do the final job.
So
what I'd like to close with is a closer look at the neuroendocrine
state itself.
Because even if everything I just described, which I
admit is a bit fanciful thinking, but I've been there before in this field,
we would want to also have something in our pocket to go after neuroendocrine
cells directly. And I've also had the
idea that in order for a tumor cell to
undergo this dramatic transition, that's quite a dramatic
parlor trick, and I suspect there might be somevulnerabilities or
liabilities that tumor cells acquire along the way.
So Jian Sun took on this question and started by making a
detailed map of the chromatin landscape changes in this state
versus then state, that state. That led to a series of candidate
targets, including a whole suite of transcription factors, which he
screened by CRISPR. And that CRISPR screen, which I won't show you the
details of, led to these five hits or five
transcription factor family hits.
ASCL1 was expected,
but FOXA1 is a hit because of what I showed you earlier, the dependency
to even get there, and in other hits as well.
So none of these can we currently
look up in a catalog and get a chemical inhibitor.
There are no drugs against any of these today.
But they all must work through co-activators to activate their
gene expression programs. So what Jian next did was a
co-activator screen.
And that co-activator screen, which I'm showing you the results of in sort
of almost raw data form here, has led to an enormous
wealth of interesting data.
But I want to call your attention to is the red arrow.
This is the dropout of sgRNAs
targeting an acetyltransferase called TIP60 or
KAT5. And you can see within each
passage, what's plotted here are four serial passages.
It's very fast dropout. But if you're looking carefully,
you'll see in the bottom panel, this is the adenocarcinoma cells, an isogenic
pair. You see dropout there. It's not quite as fast, but this is
entirely consistent with the fact that this gene is considered an
essential gene based on DepMap. So why would we pursue this
any further? Well, we decided we want to look at this
chemically. It turns out there's no viable chemical
inhibitors of this drug that have been reported by anybody in the
literature. So we took advantage of a trick that Jay Bradner's lab
first developed some years ago, and that is this system
called the dTAG system. So here the idea is you
engineer
a special tag into your protein of interest
that's a hook for a degrader molecule, a
molecular glue that will degrade that protein.
So we engineered that into the neuroendocrine cells, the adenocarcinoma
cells, normal prostate cells, and fibroblasts.
And you can see in a dose response fashion, we get beautiful
degradation of our TIP60 protein in these cells.
But the reason I'm showing you this is we see a very dramatic shift in the
dependency of cells on TIP60, depending
on their lineage. So this yellow orange curve
is the neuroendocrine cells. And you can see that we have an
IC50 at a drug concentration that is not completely
eliminating all of TIP60 protein in all of the cells.
So if we could develop a small molecule inhibitor
and perhaps bring it into the clinic, there might be a therapeutic
index.
So the
next question is: What is TIP60? TIP60, as I mentioned,
is an acetyltransferase.
TIP60 protein in this complex is shown here, is part of
a large mega Dalton complex that has at least 17
subunits. And it has these three functions, the histone
acetylation, which is mediated by this subunit.
It's also involved in a process known as H2A,
H2AX exchange. H2AX is a variant histone.
And that process is carried out by this scaffold protein
known as EP300. Which by the way, was also a hit in the screen.
Its potency is similar to what I showed you for the
catalytic subunit. And the complex also
has three or four reader domain proteins, which are important in
binding chromatin and also are potential handles for drug
ability.
So the next question we asked is: What's the substrate for
TIP60 in our system? And it's very clear that it's H2AX
itself.
You can see complete loss of this acetylation mark, both in the
adenocarcinoma state as well as in the neuroendocrine state.
In data I don't have time to show you,
we can show that this acetylation is absolutely critical for the
activity in neuroendocrine proliferation.
The enzymatic activity of the protein is required in order to rescue a
knockout. And even more compelling, if you mutate these
lysine residues, the lysine 4 and lysine 7 to
non-acetylatable residues,
and you cannot rescue the cells completely.
So this is clearly a key signal that is happening
in these cells that's driving proliferation.
So let's go back to the transcription factors that were the hits in the screen.
So I'm going to show you a very large heat map
of cut-and-run experiments where we look at the chromatin localization of
each transcription factor, the various chromatin marks, and TIP60
itself. And the plot is organized by those
enhancers that are open in the adeno start state versus those that are
open in the neuroendocrine state, as defined by this ATAC plot.
And what you can see, and you can see how much work this was,
is there's a remarkable coincidence if you look carefully at
each
of these transcription factors and the corresponding marks with
each other in each lineage. It's as if they're all on top of each other,
working as an orchestra together to drive this transition.
I also want to point out
that MYC, which was a hit in the screen for dependency,
has an interesting sort of subtext, and that is that in the
adenocarcinoma state, it's cMYC that is the dependency.
But in the neuroendocrine state, it's lMYC, and that's because these undergo a
paralog shift in expression. I'll come back to
that.So it looked like a remarkable
coincidence of binding of all those peaks.
If you look one by one and really carefully annotate that, some
themes start to come out. One is that Ascl1 has the greatest overlap
with all of the other transcription factors, and that's shown by this heat map.
The other is that Tip60 overlaps primarily with the Myc
peaks.
That sets up a really interesting hypothesis, and that is, is
Tip60 and Myc sort of closely partnered in some way?
In other words, is Tip60 the co-activator for Myc?
And the answer is yes. And the first clue for that is that if we did
principal component analysis of changes in the transcriptomes within
just a few days of knocking them down before the proliferation effects are
seen, you see that the Tip60 and the Myc
plots are indistinguishable.
We can show that they bind in a complex in a coimmunoprecipitation experiment.
And if we use the dTAG trick again to now, and this time degrade L-Myc,
which works extremely well, you can see the loss of binding in a cut-and-run
assay. You also, within just six hours of starting to degrade
L-Myc, you see loss of Tip60 binding.
So this pretty much puts a very clear
line of evidence that Myc
and Tip60 partner up.
The next question is, what do they regulate?
Well, if we take this data from over here and
look at the gene sets that are downregulated, we see a pretty interesting
phenomenon. First of all, the Myc and Tip60 gene sets
only regulate cell growth and proliferation, whereas
Ascl1 as well as Sox1 and 11 regulate
that as well. And
data I don't have time to show, that's through direct upregulation of Myc,
and they also regulate the neuroendocrine identity.
So to close,
we went back to the dTAG system one more time to
compare the dependency of cells in the adeno state
versus the neuroendocrine state on their relative Myc paralog.
And what you can see here is the degradation works in both systems,
but we also see this dramatic shift to the left, similar to what I showed you with
Tip60 in the neuroendocrine state, showing greater addiction on
Myc.
And the really surprising result here is in trying to
sort of understand how it is that this addiction develops.
We see a switch in the coactivator usage of Myc.
So I showed you a minute ago that in the neuroendocrine state, if you
degrade L-Myc, you see loss of Tip60 binding, showing that
they are tightly coupled. But if we do the same experiment in the adeno state
degrading c-Myc, there's no change in Tip60.
So there's a dependence upon c-Myc in the adeno state, but it's
through a different set of coactivators.
So to wrap it up,
I've shown you that the adeno state moves to the neuroendocrine state
through a series of changes that take time, with chromatin
rewiring driven by FoxA1 and TEAD
relocalization. That sets a new state, which has this
exquisite dependence upon Myc homologs, and
a partnership with Tip60, which
raises the very intriguing question: Is there a therapeutic index
for targeting Myc by targeting its coactivator?
So my last slide is to go back to what I said four years ago.
Maybe we can beat lineage plasticity if we understand the molecular details.
And what I've shown you is that Rb1 loss sets up the
process.
We use the word priming. We don't know what exactly that means molecularly,
because at a chromatin level, there's not dramatic differences, but they're
poised to undergo a transition if you poke them in the right way.
And the poking here is loss of extracellular matrix engagement
through integrin, and loss of Yap/TAD, and loss of Notch activation.
And as I showed you, we can toggle this in the laboratory.
We can do it convincingly in vitro. We're now trying to do it in animals.
And then I'll conclude with the point I made on the last slide, is Tip60
becomes quite interesting as a potential therapeutic target.
We need to make a chemical inhibitor that has legs, and that's what we're working
on now. Thank you for listening, and
it's been an honor.
Thank you, Dr. Sawyers, for that excellent talk.
Our next speaker is Dr. Carl H. June. Dr.
June
is the Richard W. Vague Professor in Immunotherapy,
Director of the Center for Cellular Immunotherapies, and Director of the
Parker Institute for Cancer Immunotherapy in the Perelman School
of Medicine at the University of Pennsylvania.
Dr. June is a physician-scientist whose laboratory studies various
mechanisms of lymphocyte activation that relate to immune
tolerance and adoptive immunotherapy for cancer and
chronic infection.
A fellow of the AACR Academy and a recipient of the
2023 AACR Award for Lifetime Achievement in Cancer
Research, Dr. June has made groundbreaking
advances in developing the first gene-edited cell
therapy for cancer and for demonstrating that adoptive T cell
therapy can induce remission and, in some cases,
cure patients with advanced cancer.
We look forward to hearing more about his work during his presentation titled
"Beyond Blood: The Evolution of CAR T Therapy for Solid
Malignancies." Please welcome Dr. June.
Well, thank you, Alice and Paul-Michel, for this
huge honor to talk this morning
and describe CAR T cell progress. My disclosures
are here.
I wanted to step back on this issue over the last 20
years, looking at this AACR report, where we've seen a
34% decline in cancer death rates.
And
a lot of this is due now to checkpoint therapies, T-cell engagers,
and
cell therapies. So immunotherapy has had a huge impact
on cancer survivorship.
And to link in with what you just saw from Charles Sawyers, it's a 25-year
anniversary since the first targeted
precision therapy, which was Imatinib
in leukemia,
to inhibit a kinase.
And if you look back
centuries ago, Cicero, two years before he was assassinated by
Mark Anthony, said that if physicians considered why
something's broken, you could fix it.
And
when I moved to Penn in 1999, Peter Nowell had
described the first genetic cause of
leukemia back
with a chromosomal translocation they
observed in 1960. And then that led to
Imatinib approval in 2001 through a series of
advancements.
The first concept of CAR T cells was in
1987 to '89, of retargeting them.
Our first patient was cured in 2010, and then we
now have FDA-approved
therapies then in 2017. So the platform's
moving much more rapidly than it has now that we have
a platform of cell and gene therapies to
advance on, and that's, I think, a good message.
When you step back right now, there are four types of CAR T cells
being tested. I will be talking today on the upper
left, using mostly autologous ex vivo
manufactured CAR T cells, but also talk about box four, which
is in vivo manufacturing of CAR cells, in this case using
lipid nanoparticles.
And so there are active areas in all of these, but at this point in
2026, all FDA-approved CAR
therapies are using autologous ex vivo manufactured cells,
and those are for seven kinds of leukemia,
lymphoma, and myeloma.
And now we also have tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes and
T-cell receptor redirected T cells approved as well.
The issue here primarily is scale and complexity of
manufacturing. But the other one really is,
as I'll discuss, how do we get these to work in solid
cancers? And for that, there's lots of work in making
next-generation CAR cells.
And I'll show today work using dual and tandem-targeted
CAR cells and then so-called armored CAR cells that
are CAR T cells that not only are redirected but also
express cytokines in this case.
So we first showed the idea of taking a
C19 CAR cell and armoring it with a cytokine called
IL-18. This is a cytokine made in the
NLRP3 inflammasome. It has its own checkpoint, which
is IL-18. And we picked that because we thought it might decrease
the chance of cytokine release syndrome.
So we conducted a first-in-human trial in patients
with lymphoma who were either CAR refractory or who
had relapsed after CAR T-cell treatment with commercially approved
CARs. And we had really a quite remarkable
finding in this trial. Those armored CARs resulted in a
75% complete response rate in these
patients and with no real change in toxicity
from what we've seen with the FDA-approved CARs.
The disappointing aspect is that down here, our
finding for this was reported in 2017 in mice
that we could armor these CAR cells, but it took until last year until we
could actually get this reported.
We need to make this a more rapid, iterative process.
So to summarize where we are with CAR T cells in
blood cancer, there's been a lot of progress.
About 60,000 patients have been treated,
and there's lots of work in other kinds of cell therapies,
such as TCR T cells and allogeneic CAR
cells and NK cells,
and then a lot of work and then in scaling out the
manufacturing.
So blood cancer is relatively simple in
its tumor microenvironment compared to solid tumors, where
we haven't had dramatic responses in general with CAR cells.
And there's a lot of reasons for that.
The tumor microenvironment is more established.
It has more checkpoints immunologically, and it also has
metabolic checkpoints that the blood cancers
don't face.
So where are we with solid cancers?
These are some of the targets shown here on the left,
and I'll be focusing on mesothelin, a tumor-associated antigen in
pancreatic cancer and ovarian cancer, and in
EGFR variant III and
glioblastoma. But the most advanced testing is being
done in a tight junction protein called
claudin 18.2.
And I'll summarize this Phase 2 trial here.
So in China, a trial was conducted in
patients with refractory gastroesophageal
cancer targeting
claudin 18.2 with autologous CAR cells.
This is the only randomized controlled trial now yet
reported with CAR T cells. And what they found
wasQuite promising. As you can see, the overall response rate
with the CAR cells compared to a standard of care therapy.
And so this is really promising. The disappointing
aspect is that it's not durable. The average
prolongation of PFS was about two months.
So we have a foot in the door now in solid cancers with CAR cells,
but we need durability to be improved.
So with that, I'll turn to what we're doing at the University of
Pennsylvania in our institute.
And first focus on glioblastoma and trials led by
Don Rork
and his team, and then move on to
mesothelin as a target in
abdominal malignancies. So
in glioblastoma, we've now conducted three trials at the University of
Pennsylvania.
The initial trial targeted mutated EGFR,
and we used intravenously administered CAR T-cells.
And in that trial, we saw no responses whatsoever.
So now we have dealt with that by two changes, and
one is making a bicistronic construct that targets both
mutated EGFR in glioblastoma, which is
present in about 60% of cases. And as well as
IL-13 receptor alpha 2, which is present in about
75% of glioblastoma.
Both of these are expressed in the same autologous T-cell so that we
have dual targeting. And,
we've now reported both an initial pilot study of six patients and the
full 18 patients treated at the
University of Pennsylvania on this IIT trial.
So it's a pretty standard trial design.
The patients have to have refractory glioblastoma, be adults.
And then,
we've tested several dose levels, with very
small amounts of CAR cells, five million cells, which
was usually what we use in mice.
And we're now giving these, via an omaya reservoir.
Our initial treatments were through intravenous administration.
So the main change here being
intra-CNS delivery
and as well as dual targeting now. And we found in this trial
a dose-dependent PK in the blood after giving
from five million up to 25 million cells.
And an area under the curve dose-dependent
increase over the first month after treatment, looking at the PK and
cerebral spinal fluid. And then in the blood, we find
very low levels in the blood of the
omaya administered cells, but with some leakage into the blood or
trafficking out from
in the highest doses treated patients.
So
we found for the first time now very encouraging findings
on imaging. And these are the first three patients
treated with gadolinium-enhanced PET
scans. And this first patient here had a day before
treatment an image showed multifocal glioblastoma with the
red and green arrows. And within two days, you can see
a massive improvement here.
And we didn't see this in the first two trials.
And we saw changes like this in all three patients
treated. So a very exciting change.
The swimmer's plot here, from Steve Bagley, sent to me
yesterday. This is updated until this month.
There's now in the 13 of 18 patients who had measurable
disease, there's been
responses observed. And with the
best responses by the RENO criteria of two
PRs and an overall disease control rate of about
70%. Now, these are the 18 patients on this
swimmer's plot.
And
the first patient or patient three here now is out 34 months,
and his tumor has not recurred
after that initial single treatment.
So we're seeing as these data mature, an improvement in
survival rate. This is much different than the initial two trials we
conducted. So how is that that it has improved,
the same kinds of tumors? And Dana Silver Bush and her group are
looking at this by studying CSF recurrent
sampling and the tumor biopsies in patients
after treatment to look for correlates of response and
resistance. And the first thing she's found is that there are
improvements in natural killer cells in the tumor
microenvironment, and there's both a discovery cohort and a
validation cohort. But the responding patients have much
higher NK cells in the tumor microenvironment than
the non-responding patients, and that correlates with PFS
in this group of patients. She's also found a negative
correlative response, and that's
Tregs. Regulatory T-cells
are inversely correlated with
survival and
changes in tumor volume here, and also
here in PFS. So the patients with the most
Tregs do the worst.
So those are two correlatives at my point.
And then just yesterday, we got this recent spatial
biology profiling
done by Wes Wilson and Andrew Rack at Penn
takingbiopsy specimens, in this case,
six to eight patients after treatment, and then using a new
platform from 10x Genomics called Atera, where you can
do on this whole transcriptome analysis.
When you do that, the
UMAPs look like this, with four identified
populations of cells with a tumor, and then
glial cells, myeloid cells, and the smallest compartment being T and
NK cells.
In this middle panel, what we see is that the amount of NK
cells increases on the spatial biology from
14% at baseline on average to 22%
after treatment in five of six of these paired
treatments. On the right-hand panel here is, unfortunately, it's a
disappointment, where we see a resistance mechanism
where the tumor cell state itself is changing
from its initial
state to a more mesenchymal-like state with,
on these gene signatures, less EGFR and aquaporin 4
expression. And the tumor cells are not randomly
distributed in the tumor microenvironment.
They're around myeloid cells, which are probably shielding
them and contributing to resistance.
So this is not unlike some of what you just saw in prostate cancer.
Lineage plasticity can unfortunately be a major cause
of resistance. So we're seeing promise and advances
with CAR cells in glioblastoma, in
stepwise-driven, small numbers of patients, but
engineering around resistance mechanisms.
Multi-epitope dual targeting has really improved
responses combined with local regional delivery
in glioblastoma, and there's many more, I think,
iterations required now to make durable responses
in most patients. But I think we have our foot in the door.
What I'd like to do now is shift to mesothelin as a
tumor-associated antigen target.
Mesothelin's a GPI-linked protein that's overexpressed
in nearly all pancreatic cancers, in serous
ovarian cancer, and in
mesotheliomas.
So we've been doing trials here for 15 years with that as a
CAR target, and we've uncovered two mechanisms of resistance,
one being impaired CAR T cell
infiltration into the pancreatic tumor
microenvironment.
And I'll be coming back to this. The other aspect we've seen
is the induction of rapid T cell exhaustion
in the CAR T cells that actually manage to get into the
tumor microenvironment. These have not been issues in blood cancer.
So in the very first trial we did with Greg
Beatty at Penn targeting metastatic pancreatic cancer, we had,
looking at these six patients, looking at imaging
after treatment, some responses in patients, with the best
being a month after treatment. This patient here
with pancreatic cancer after a tolerance
mesothelin-specific CAR T cells.
At baseline, this patient had widely metastatic disease in the liver,
and he also had in the body of his unresected primary mass.
A month later, we had a really gratifying result in the
liver, and you can see that here as well on imaging.
But paradoxically, the primary pancreatic tumor actually progressed
during that time.
So the metastatic lesions were more sensitive
than the primary, and that patient progressed
and died rapidly. So we've been studying that
as mixed response, and
this is work that Angela Aznar did in my lab with Shelly
Berger's lab at Penn, where we looked in vitro at in these
mesothelin CAR T cells ex vivo and repeatedly
stimulating them,
the CAR T cells, by repeated additions of a
KRAS mutant pancreatic tumor line.
And what we found was rapid and widespread transcriptomic
and epigenetic shifts in the CAR T cells
that were published here. We found a 30-gene signature
in the cells that became inactive, and we also found the induction of
transcription factors in the CAR T cells, such as SOX4
and ID3, that aren't in healthy T cells.
So we're now looking at ways of getting around
this. So we've been working with targeting the CAFs,
the carcinoma-associated fibroblasts, in the microenvironment of
pancreatic cancer with LM Puré at Penn and Steve
Albelda for many years. And LM's hypothesis is that if we
can decaffeinate, if you will, the tumor microenvironment,
we may then be able to improve trafficking of CAR T cells into the
tumor microenvironment. So to do that, we made
CARs against both murine FAP, fibroblast activation protein,
and made them as second-generation CARs with a BBZeta
signaling domains
and showed that these CAR T cells could eradicate
FAP-expressing fibroblasts in this case.
And we did that against murine or human fibroblasts
that were activated like that. So then what we did is we've now
tested in an autochthonous KPC
pancreatic cancer model in mice,
CAR T cells targeting either mesothelin or,
so mouse mesothelin or mouse FAP. And as
these tumors grow, and these are controlled T cells that are non-targeted,
the mesothelin CAR T cells just have a minor effect,
whereas we get much better control with the anti-FAP
CAR T cells here.
AndWe then tested sequential
infusions, and this is complicated, but we gave either
two mice that had these KPC tumors
an infusion of syngeneic CAR T cells
targeting these mesothelin or FAP, and then did
crossovers two weeks later. And what you can see is
that there's progressive disease basically in all of these mice except
those that got the combination of an anti-FAP CAR T cell
followed two weeks later by an anti-mesothelin
CAR T cells, and that was reflected in enhanced survival curves.
So we think and where we're headed is polytherapy here
with cell therapies targeting the fibroblasts,
and then following with the tumor cells, in this case, a
mesothelin CAR T cells, which should enhance responses.
And this could be combined with T-cell engagers and checkpoint therapies
as well, the strategy.
So another approach that we have been
working on at Penn is with my colleagues, John Epstein, Andrew
Weisman, and Alain Pure E.A., is lipid nanoparticle delivery
of these fibroblast-activated protein CAR T cells.
And here we're using lipid nanoparticles manufactured similar as a
COVID vaccine, but having an extracellular antibody,
in this case an scFv, attached so that when
the nanoparticles are given, they can transduce and give
their cargo, an RNA CAR,
right into T cells entering in through the CD5 or CD8
molecule. And then they're transiently expressed on the surface
of the T cell. So it's an RNA, it's not permanent transduction.
And what we initially showed is that we could target
fibrotic tissue, such as in the heart after heart
injury, and then get regeneration by just killing the
fibroblast-activated cells with these cells that are
transiently made in the mouse after
tail vein transduction. So in this work that's impressed,
what we've done is compare these FAP-CARs made by lipid
nanoparticles,
with retrovirally transduced T cells that are
made in a standard way and given via
tail vein injection in mice. And this shows
through the retrovirus CD5 positive CAR T
cells and also with FAP staining,
the lipid nanoparticles. So we get efficient expression in both
cases. And much to my surprise, what we're finding is
in mice then that have these pancreatic KPC tumors,
that
mice given control lipid nanoparticles,
they have progressive disease. But if they have the anti-FAP CAR T
cells that are just fRNA delivered, not even
permanently, they have tumor control, and that's better than if they have
the retrovirally transduced FAP CAR cells.
And that's reflected as well in the tumor
microenvironment. So targeting the stroma looks to be very
promising via various ways in
fibrosin tumors such as pancreatic cancer,
and may well make other therapies that had failed in the past
more efficacious. So that's one way to improve the
response of CAR cells in pancreatic cancer,
is targeting the stroma.
Another approach that we're pursuing, and others, is the issue of
exhaustion. And so exhaustion, as I mentioned, occurs, we
found a 30-gene signature
when we did in vitro re-stimulations.
And it's due to many factors, immune checkpoints, metabolic checkpoints,
vascular changes in the tumor microenvironment.
There are some reviews on this field here.
Some of this is the same as what occurs to T cells in checkpoint therapy,
and some is more specific to what happens in a T cell that's been
transduced to express a CAR cell. So
this is
that model where we looked at the in vitro changes after
chronic antigen exposure, CAE, in
vitro. And then
what we then did and published last summer was look at patients
after treatment then with the mesothelin CAR cells, and we
found the same gene signatures in the patients in vivo.
We retrieved and single-cell RNA
sequenced tumor biopsies after treatment of patients,
and we could see, for instance, these are endogenous CAR cells.
These are CAR cells that have the transcript in metastatic
liver.
The CAR cells themselves have these transcription factors that aren't in a healthy
T cell,
and other checkpoints expressed in these cells,
such as PD-1 and TIGIT and so on. So there's a rapid
induction in these patients of this exhaustion signature.
So what can we do about it? And this is where we are in the
field, which is doing forward genetic screens to try to prevent
this from happening in, as we found in
vitro and in vivo, in these CAR cells after giving to
patients. So we're taking cells and then using
nucleases to knock out genes and isolate those that might make
them better. Now, we first found by following patients,
in leukemia patients thatWe had extraordinary
performance of a car that had, had the gene
Tet2 knocked out by the introduction when the
lentivirus went into the CAR T cell, it caused insertional
mutagenesis and knocked down Tet2.
And so that patient actually is cured, and the T cells
worked much better in that patient with Tet2 disruption.
And then in another study, in a genome-wide study in mice,
Hongbo Chi, who's going to speak later today, found
that mice knocking out the gene RAG1
made in a CD8 T cell receptor model
B16-OVA, that the T cells worked much better if they
had the gene RAG1 knocked out. So those are single-chain
disruptions. There's been now several publications where people
have knocked out two different genes at once.
Joe Freidt at our group knocked out BLIMP1 and NR4A3 with
Cas9 and found better
performance in mouse models. We knocked out RAG1 and
ROCO1 and found also very improved function, and there have been others
that have been published with targeted dual gene disruption.
What hasn't been done, though, is screening
in a way to look
for what would be maybe synergistically knocking out different genes.
And this is a four-year ongoing project now between my
lab and Zhen-Yu Shi's at Penn, where we've knocked out a pool
of genes and then asked which ones are best to actually knock out
together to improve CAR T cell function.
And to do this, we're using the nuclease Cas12, which allows you to
knock out multiple genes at one time
and then testing both in vitro and in vivo in
various mouse models for candidates that are synergistic.
And so Cas12 can process two different guide
RNAs at one time, and then we express CAR T cells.
So it's a two-vector system that we use to do this pooled
screen. And we've picked 32 genes to screen.
They are surface molecules like CTLA-4, Tet2,
BRD4, transcription factors ID3, SOX4, et cetera,
and then some positive and negative control genes.
When we take this pool, and then there are actually about
7,000 combinations of knockouts, and that's something we can
now screen at a depth of 500 to 1,000
in mouse models and in vitro.
And so we're screening
both in vitro and in prostate cancer and in our pancreatic
cancer models, and were used in this data,
three different healthy donors who are all CMV negative.
And we found then if we knock out all 32 genes that the
T cells, this is Exceligence data from a healthy donor,
they eradicate tumor over a period of a week
much better than cells that don't have any of those genes knocked out.
So we don't know which of the 32 genes here made this pool work
better, but they do. And they also knock and kill a tumor much
better with that library of 32 genes knocked out than
if they just had the CAR T cells targeted, in this case,
mesothelin. So what we found now is
both in pancreatic cancer and
prostate cancer models, that we find genes
that are synergistic when they're together.
And so what we have here is a filter.
It's called better than both singles, and that's either
knocking out both genes with one guide RNA or both guide
RNAs, so having two ways of targeting the same gene.
There are 26 different gene pairs showed here, and all the
ones in blue are those where it's synergistic, two of them, et
cetera.
And the first one was a single gene knockout, it comes down
here, and that's two genes knocked out of RAG1.
So there are synergistic combinations that we've identified,
and we've looked here
at what those are, and this is the best single gene knockouts
on log-fold change on improvement of coming into tumor
microenvironments. It's been reported that CIB1 knockout
improves performance in solid tumors, and those are
the best you can get with any single gene knockout.
And we found a number of pairs now that are much better than any single
knockout combination. And we've looked at it in many different
ways and filtered to be very stringent about these calls.
And what we're finding is that transcription factors such as
EGR2 and then in this case, RAG1 or ROCO1
knockout. So when we look here at these panels where
there's synergistic knockouts, both in vivo or in
vitro, and we've looked here in bold, it means its guide pair
was enriched in both orientations, underlined, it was agnostic to the
guide pair. What we find is that in
both these common gene knockout PTPN2,
EGR2 or RAG1 and EGR2
are synergistic in several tumor models.
So we're excited that there may be ways to go forward to make more
potent cells
in future trials. Interestingly, the gene that we
found in blood cancer, Tet2, did not come out in this screen.
In solid tumors, that did not enhance unlike
in our blood cancers that we've seen in multiple other models.
And we have not ever seen CAR T cell
transformation with knocking out all these genes.
So I'll conclude, where the field is, is moving
into precision targeting. I've shown dual targeting
today enhances dramatically responses in
glioblastoma.Enhanced persistence is needed
to overcome exhaustion and then target
escape. So I think the field's making rapid progress and has
a lot of promise. I'd like to thank all my colleagues at the University
of Pennsylvania over the years that have led to this
data, and I've mentioned them over
the course of this. So thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. June. Our next speaker this morning is Dr.
Georg E. Winter. Dr. Winter is Adjunct Principal
Investigator at CeMM Research Center for Molecular Medicine
and the Scientific Director of the Aithera Research Institute for
Biomedical Artificial Intelligence of the Austrian Academy of Sciences.
His laboratory works at the interface of chemical biology,
proteostasis, and gene control, focusing on the development of
novel chemical strategies that elucidate the fundamental
principles of small molecule action on transcriptional regulation and the
ubiquitin protease system. His current focus is on small
molecule degraders, which induce proximity between a target protein of
interest and an E3 ubiquitin ligase to prompt
ubiquitination and proteasomal degradation of the target protein.
Today, Dr. Winter will discuss his work in a presentation
titled, "Chemical Rewiring of Biological Circuits for Cancer
Therapy: Targeted Protein Degradation and Beyond." Please join
me in welcoming Dr. Winter.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Michelle. Yeah, it's a tremendous pleasure to present in this
plenary session and to represent the chemical
biology and chemistry community here.
So I want to start by sharing my disclosures.
And so we can get started. So our research is focusing on addressing this
limitation that only around 20% of all human proteins are
addressable with small molecules.
And the reason for this is, I would argue that as a community, we've
adapted a very inhibitor-centric mindset, meaning that we
want to fashion small organic molecules that bind to
hydrophobic pockets on target proteins with the intent of functionally
antagonizing those proteins.
And so the problem is that the remaining 80% of the human proteome simply lack
such ligatable and biochemically active pockets.
So the question that emerges is how can we pursue these remaining targets?
And our approach is to try to completely shift
perspective and move away from trying to identify small molecules that bind to a
target and inhibit its function towards small molecules that act as
what we like to refer as chemical neomorphs.
Small molecules that change the function of a target protein and endow them with
new functionalities that evolution hasn't taught them.
So our strategy is to capitalize on the principle that proximity
induction is a fundamental regulatory principle in biology.
So biology very much works by regulating proximity of
macromolecules. If you think about the molecular scale, thinking about how
transcription regulation or signal transduction works.
But also on the cellular level, we think about immune activation, also
processes such as metastasis formation.
So what does it have to do with drug discovery?
Well, we do know since a very long time that small molecules can
induce protein-protein interactions.
And we also know since a long time with using synthetic ligands and
using tagged proteins, that inducing the proximity of
proteins can be sufficient to prompt a biologically downstream
response. And this has been very elegantly shown for processes
as diverse as signal transduction,
cell death induction, also nuclear import.
So we can conclude that by stabilizing protein-protein interactions, small
molecules can indeed endow proteins with new functionalities.
And this is also exactly the principle that targeted protein degradation
is built on. It's built on small molecules that induce proximity between
an E3 ubiquitin ligase, a member of the cellular degradation machinery, and
a target protein of interest that is typically disease-causing.
And so this can be done, for instance, by bifunctional molecules, so-called
PROTACs. These are molecules that were innovated by Craig Crews and Ray Deshaies,
which are bifunctional, meaning that they have two arms with which they
simultaneously ligand the E3 ligase and the target protein of interest,
induce proximity, cause target ubiquitination, and degradation by the
proteasome.
So the drawback of these early designs was that these PROTACs were peptidic
in nature, meaning that there was a limited efficacy that
prevented in vivo application of this
technology. So back then, when joining Jay Bradner's lab as a
postdoc, we capitalized on the finding by Hiroshi Handa and his
team, namely that the small molecule thalidomide has
an E3
ligase called cereblon as its endogenous binding partner.
So based on that knowledge, we could fashion bifunctional small
molecules that, on the one hand, bind to the E3
ligase cereblon, and on the other hand, bind to the
bromodomain of BET4, a protein that you'll hear more of during that
talk.
And so we were very pleased to see that with this molecule, when we treat leukemia
cells, we saw immediate and acute degradation in the nanomolar range.
And most importantly, we could also, with a single application in tumor-bearing
animals, detect BET4 degradation inside the tumor.
And so together with work from, again, Craig Crews and also Alessio Ciulli,
also involving the E3 ligase VHL, this really set the stage
for a broad therapeutic exploration of that space.
So today, there's more than 25 PROTACs in human
clinical investigation,
mostly in oncology. And I think they've also really redefined what we
consider drug-like. These are molecules that are now made routinely
orally bioavailable, and there's a lot of excitement in that
field.Nevertheless, I think it's also fair to point out that there
are certain limitations in the PROTAC technology, and this is particularly
when the target that we want to eliminate has large
intrinsically disordered regions that it's hard to bind.
Because fundamentally, remember, a PROTAC still needs to bind to the target protein
that we want to eliminate.
But luckily, this is a limitation that is addressed by another
modality within targeted protein degradation, the so-called molecular
gludegrades.
And so molecular gludegrades, I think, really got a boost in the field when
Ben Ebert's lab and Bill Kilian's lab were studying the mechanism of this
very prominent anti-myeloma drug, lenalidomide.
And so what they identified is that when lenalidomide binds cereblon,
it also creates a new substrate interface, which causes the
dimerization or the induced proximity to different zinc finger transcription
factors, such as ICSRF1 and ICSRF3, inducing,
again, the ubiquitination and degradation by the proteasome.
The important difference to PROTACs is that here,
lenalidomide or this class of IMiD drugs, they don't bind to these zinc
finger transcription factors in isolation.
They simply bind to the ligase, reshape its surface, and this is
sufficient to orchestrate several protein-protein interactions between the ligase
and the transcription factor.
So with those studies and related studies, the field was really presented
with almost a holy grail blueprint because we had an FDA-approved
medicine that was then
identified to induce the degradation of a truly unligandable,
undruggable protein. And that set a lot of motivation for
the field for us and others to really think about new discovery
approaches, to think about new mechanisms, and to expand the scope
of molecular gludegrades to new targets and new E3 ligases.
And so over the next couple of slides, I want to share with you a couple of
vignettes of work that my group has been contributing in this space.
So we developed several approaches to purposefully identify molecular
gludegrades. First, I want to introduce a phenotypic approach,
where Christina Maiorano, former postdoc in my lab who now is leading her
independent group at the IRB in Barcelona, set out initially to map
all genes that are required for small molecule degraders to work.
And this led to the identification of a gene called UBE2M,
which acts as a general light switch.
It controls the activity of more than 200 E3 ligase in any given cell.
And this allowed us to set up phenotypic discovery approaches, where we would test
libraries of compounds in cells that are wild type for UBE2M and cells that are
mutant for UBE2M. And amongst others, this allowed us to identify
a novel molecular glue mechanism where a small molecule induces
the proximity between a kinase, a CDK12,
and DDB1, an adaptor of an E3 ligase.
And this leads then to the ubiquitination and degradation of the
undruggable protein cycling K, which typically partners up with
CDK12 and regulates its activity.
So in a more recent study and in a more target-centric study
that we collaborated with Michael Erb, who led these studies,
the goal was to move away from these phenotypic approaches towards more
target-centric approaches. And basically, find ways of how we can turn a
binder of a target protein into a molecular gludegrade.
And so what Michael's team did is, again, leveraging this bromodomain
binder of BET4 and perform high-throughput chemistry, systematically
derivatizing what we call the exit vector, which is the outward-facing part of the
small molecule,
and making a library of more than 3,000 analogs with high-throughput chemistry, and
then directly testing them in cellular degradation assays.
So basically what Michael and his team did is that they systematically
adapted the surface of BET4 with a hypothesis that one of these
chemical modifications would stabilize a latent interaction with a
yet to be identified E3 ligase to cause its ubiquitination and
degradation.
And so we then had to find this particular molecule called
DHTC3 and found that this induces the
degradation of BET4 by co-opting a ligase called
FBXO3 which up to this point has not been addressed for targeted
protein degradation purposes.
As a next example, this is a collaboration with Alessia Ciulli in Dundee.
I want to share with you how by deeply characterizing this bifunctional
molecule that you see here called IBG-1, we identified a new
modality in targeted protein degradation.
So this molecule was initially reported in the patent literature by Mitsubishi
Pharma. And you again see this is clearly a bifunctional molecule, again
binding to BET4 with one arm. And then it has this
so-called arylsulfonamide on the other side that was known to
bind to a particular E3 ligase called DCAF15.
We tested this molecule and found that it is exquisitely potent in cells,
but then got interested because when we take cells where we have
deleted or knocked out DCAF15, that molecule was just as
potent. Clearly establishing that DCAF15 is not the functionally
required ligase.
To identify the ligase that is involved, we set up a CRISPR screen,
knocking out every E3 ligase encoded in the human genome and asking the question,
knockout of which ligase prevents IBG-1 from inducing BET4
degradation.
And this led to the identification of another E3 ligase called
DCAF16. And despite the very similar nomenclature, I think you can
appreciate by looking at the structure of both proteins in yellow bounds to their
adaptor protein, DDB1, that those
are quite dissimilar.
So we went on to further characterize IBG-1 and made a couple of curious
observations. The first one,
maybe as expected, when we test binding affinity of this molecule to the
E3 ligase, we did realize that indeed that molecule potently binds to
DCAF15, notably the ligase that functionally is not required.
Simultaneously, we could not detect any measurable binding to DCAF16, the ligase
that we have established as functionally
relevant.So what you need to know is that
RAD4 has two bromodomains at its N-terminus.
And typically, for any given PROTAC, it's sufficient to just have one of those
bromodomains fuse it to luciferase or to GFP, and the PROTAC
can degrade this fusion protein. However, with this molecule, IBG-1, it
was quite different because we needed both of the N-terminal bromodomains to be
accessible by the molecule.
And so these and other observations really only materialized when we
solved the cryo-EM structure of this ternary assembly and
found that counterintuitively, IBG-1 is not acting in trans,
binding the ligase and the target, but it acts in cis and it bridges these
two N-terminal bromodomains of RAD4, and this is then
sufficient to nucleate an interaction with DCAP16,
basically stabilizing a preexisting latent and weak interaction.
So we termed this intermolecular bivalent gluing.
We could show that this is extendable to other E3 ligases,
such as DCAP11.
And, we could structurally optimize these compounds.
And given that there is a large fraction of proteins in the human proteome that
have more than one domain, we think this is also potentially
widely applicable.
The last vignette I want to share with you
leads us a little bit away and
kind of starts with this observation that there are these episodic reports
of small molecules that were identified or developed as
inhibitors but still induced the degradation of their target proteins.
And this has been reported, for instance, for certain gene control factors
such as BCL6, lamin, or the estrogen receptor, but it's
particularly prevalent also for kinase and kinase inhibitors.
And so Natalie Schols, another former postdoc in my lab who
started this year her independent lab at the NKI in Amsterdam, was
interested in this phenomenon but wanted to approach it really from a systems-level
perspective, wanted to understand how frequently these events occur,
whether proximity induction is the underlying mechanistic principle, or whether
other mechanistic principles are at play.
So in order to systematically address that, she did a lot of work.
She made 100 different cell lines, each expressing a different kinase with a
luciferase fusion, and then exposed these 100 different cell lines against a
library of 1,500 kinase inhibitors, each in
time-ranging measurements. So she created overall more than
1.2 million protein stability measurements but did identify
450 new cases of inhibitor-induced target destabilization.
And so we looked into detail with some of them.
And I think what was very curious for see that in neither of those cases, we really
saw a traditional proximity induction where the kinase would be
paired with an E3 ligase that it typically doesn't meet.
Rather, what we see that these inhibitors lock a kinase in a state that
is more prone to be turned over by its native ligase, which just make these kinases
a bit more visible to their native degradation systems and we call this hence
supercharging of native degradation systems.
And mechanistically, we saw this can play out with different
mechanisms. So this can be ligand-induced oligomerization of
kinases, ligand-induced changes in localization of the kinase or also
activity state.
And so this was published late last year.
And early this year in a collaboration with Herbert Waldmann and Brenda Schulman
lab,
we could also expand the concept of inhibitor-induced supercharging outside of the
kinase or outside of the kinome,
as we report a new class of inhibitors for
IDO1, an immuno-oncology target that also induced the degradation of
IDO1. We found that this occurs via cofactor displacement and then
IDO1 adopts an APOL-like state that is then
more
effectively cleared by its native E3 ligase, KLHDC3,
that we also identified in this study.
So in conclusion, what I wanted to communicate with these last couple of
slides is that really our repertoire, our understanding and the repertoire of
targeted protein degradation is gradually increasing.
We're, as a community, very hopeful that this will precipitate in new
medicines for patients.
And to lead in the next part of my talk, I also want to share with you that there
is this paradoxic example that we still have FDA-approved
degraders in the clinic without really understanding
how they work.
And so this leads me to the second part where I want to
introduce a class of medicine that are called selective estrogen receptor degraders
or SERDs, which are cornerstone of the treatment of
ER-positive breast cancer patients, particularly relapsing and
metastatic patients. And the most well-known
SERD is a small molecule called fulvestrant.
It's clinically approved since 20 years.
And again, I think it's mind-blowing that really the way how fulvestrant
induces the degradation of the estrogen receptor has not been
understood in detail.
So this is something that we wanted to change, and this is a collaboration where we
teamed up with Nico Tomas lab at EPFL.
And for lack of time, I'm going to just share two large experiments that
we set up initially. One was, again, a CRISPR screen where we knock out
every gene in the human genome, asking knockout of which genes prevents SERDs from
inducing estrogen receptor degradation.
The second experiment was a proximity labeling coupled to proteomics, where we
can now ask the question, what are the interactors of the estrogen receptor when
it's liganded by fulvestrant or by other SERDs?
And so that allowed us to really map the entire pathway that is required for SERDs
in inducing estrogen receptor degradation.
It really shed light on another post-translational modification that is called
SUMOylation, which is a ubiquitin-like modification, and just as
ubiquitin is set on a target protein via a cascade of an SUMO E1,
E2, and E3. And we indeed mapped that entire pathway,
including several members of the PIAS family of SUMO E3
ligases. And so the SUMO-related estrogen receptors
then recognized and turned over by two fully
redundant ubiquitin ligases, RNF4 and
RNF111.So we were then surprised, right?
Typically, all the molecular degraders that I've told you about so far,
they basically functionalize this step here.
They reprogram an E3 ubiquitin ligase.
However, when we biochemically reconstituted this system, we
learned that the biochemical or the direct biochemical
activity of SERDs is actually to induce SUMOylation.
So they don't rewire an E3 ubiquitin ligase, they act as
SUMO-inducing a small molecule drugs.
So now having met the degradation pathway for the first time, we could also ask
the question, how relevant is the degradation of the estrogen receptor actually for
the efficacy of these medicines? And so we started by
performing a xenograft study, either using cell lines that are
proficient for RNF4 and RNF111, or in
cells using cells where both of these E3 ligases have been knocked out.
And again, to our surprise, we realized that fulvestrant doesn't really care.
If we deprive it of its activity of inducing ER degradation,
those molecules are just as active.
We could validate the same finding with transcriptional reporters.
So what you see here is basically a gene set of the estrogen receptor.
If the bar goes down, that means the drug is inhibiting ER transcription.
If we test this with a PROTAC, you see it go down.
If we knock out the relevant ligase, in this case, cereblon, the PROTAC loses this
activity. Looks very different with the SERDs, where you see a
very strong anti-estrogenic response.
If we knock out these two ligases, this is not impaired.
And so if we then moved to longer
proliferation studies that allow us more granular control over the concentrations
that we test compared to the in vivo experiment, we found actually something that
was particularly curious for us. We found exactly the opposite of what we would
have expected. So when we stabilize the estrogen receptor by
removing both of those ligases, SERDs don't lose their activity, they
actually get more potent. Insinuating that they really require
estrogen receptor to unlock their full potency and that there
is some sort of dominant repressive pharmacology at play.
So having established that degradation is functionally inconsequential for SERDs,
we naturally ask the question, what are the effectors that are driving its
efficacy and performed another genome wide screen.
Here now looking at viability or cellular fitness as a readout.
So we knock out every gene and ask the question, knock out of which gene prevents
the activity or this anti-cytostatic effect of the SERDs.
And, again, interestingly, we find core
members of the SUMOylation machinery, letting us conclude
that full SERD efficacy really requires active SUMOylation.
Again, this is something that we could also validate when looking at
transcriptional profiling. So again, this is a gene set enrichment analysis,
and you see that fulvestrant has these very strong,
antagonistic properties on ER transcription.
However, if we block cells with a pharmacological inhibitor of the SUMOylation
cascade, we completely revert that phenotype, meaning that,
again, SUMOylation is required for the full ER antagonism elicited
by SERDs.
Mechanistically, we could found that when the estrogen receptor is
decorated with these SUMO chains, it's also bound by a network of different
transcriptional repressors, particularly the NURD complex, that keeps this
in a transcriptionally fully inert state, immobilized on chromatin.
This immobilization is also something that colleagues at Genentech have shown a
couple of years ago.
So in sum, what I've shared with you, and this is still unpublished work
about our studies of the mechanism of action of SERDs, is that fulvestrant
binds to the estrogen receptor and directly induces ER SUMOylation.
Then the SUMOylated ER is ubiquitinated and degraded by the
redundant action of these two E3 ligases, called RNF4 and
RNF11. However, ER degradation is
inconsequential or in some stages or in some settings, even detrimental
for the transcriptional disruption cytostatic activity of SERDs.
In contrast, we found that SUMOylation is causative for the full transcriptional
disruption, and the cellular efficacy of SERDs.
And mechanistically, we believe that the SUMOylated ER is really bound
by transcriptional repressors immobilized on chromatin and acting as
a dominant repressive signal.
And
importantly to state, fulvestrant is not the only drug that induces
SUMOylation of its target and then some sort of immobilization on chromatin.
In fact,
once we got into this space, you then realize that there is actually a number of
FDA-approved drugs or agents that are in clinical investigation that do
exactly the same. Mechanistically, via different pathways or different
principles. But in the end, they lead to immobilization and
SUMOylation of the targets on chromatin.
And so also given that there's a lot of evidence emerging in the field and
Lacra Pinto's lab in Stanford is leading that space, that SUMOylation is
also really a central cue in transcriptional repression.
We really believe that this is maybe one of those cases, just as targeted protein
degradation a decade ago, where we have a clinical validation of a modality
that was never purposefully developed that way.
And that it could be a strategy to purposefully shut down
oncogenic transcription.
Okay, so for the last couple of minutes, I want to go back to the beginning, where
I've told you that small molecule degraders are chemical neomorphs
that rewire an E3 ubiquitin ligase to, in the end,
elicit a very potent loss of function on the target protein.
So we rewire an effector to eliminate a target.
And I think from a conceptual perspective, it's also interesting to
review that really we've, as a community, put a lot of effort
on these loss of function therapies, right?
Maybe with exception of CAR T-cells or T-cell engagers, and I'm sure there are many
other exceptions, but I think in the field of small molecule discovery, it's fair
to say that frequently we're looking for one particular wire, want to
cut it, and then hope that in this very complex wiring of cancer cells, that this
is sufficient to induce cell death.
And so over the last couple of slides, I want to share with you what could we do
if, instead of rewiring an effector to eliminate the target, we
could just directly rewire the
target.Again, as everything, this is
motivated by work that others have been doing before.
And there's two studies I want to highlight.
One earlier study from the Bradner and Sari lab, where they could show
that you can recruit BD4 to repressive and repetitive regions in the
chromatin, and this is then sufficient to nucleate a transcriptional
response. And then, a more recent study by Nathaniel Gray and Chirag
Kheradchi where they could show that you can also recruit BD4, but also other
transcriptional co-activators to BCL6 and thereby actively
flipping a switch and turning this repressor into an activator.
And we felt that this is incredibly exciting field.
And so we wanted to basically ask the question whether we can also
reprogram chromatin remodeling complexes.
So again, we focus here on BCL6. BCL6 is a
transcriptional repressor. This is a target in lymphomas that sits on
chromatin and represses the activity of different genes, particularly
also proapoptotic genes. So our therapeutic
hypothesis was that maybe we can recruit the BAF complex to
change chromatin conformation around BCL6 binding sites and to
establish a chromatin state that is more permissive for transcriptional activity.
Many of you will be aware of the BAF complex.
It's mutated in 20% of all human cancer.
But in this case, again, let me rephrase.
We are not trying to inhibit the BAF complex.
We just try to borrow it to effectively rewire
BCL6 as a target.
So together with Christian Steinebach, we developed bifunctional
molecules that on the one hand binds to the BTB domain of BCL6, and on the
other hand bind to the bromodomain of SMARCA2/4 which are the
catalytic active subunits of the BAF complex.
So again, in in vitro experiments, we could show that we can effectively induce
proximity between BCL6 and SMARCA2/4.
And we could also immobilize this bromodomain ligand
and perform chemoproteomics. And that allowed us really to basically pull
down the entire BAF complex, letting us conclude that with
liganding this bromodomain, we really have chemical control and chemical
accessibility of the entire BAF complex.
We then set up a cellular target engagement assay,
that basically tells us that at the concentration of around a micromolar, we only
engage between 5 or 10% of the BAF complex that is
expressed in a given lymphoma cell line.
And then we performed cut and run experiments.
So this is similar to Chip-seq, where we can track abundance or
positioning of different factors on a chromatin-wide scale.
Here we focus on known BCL6 target sites.
And what these graphs tell us is that indeed we can see a recruitment
of the BAF complex. Here, cut and run data showing for
SMARCA4 that this goes hand-in-hand with an eviction of
BCL6 at those sites and then an establishment of
transcriptionally active and permissive chromatin states.
The functional consequence of this is a transcriptional induction of BCL6
target genes that are specific for this molecule that we termed
TRIP1,
and also important induction of apoptotic cell
death. Which again, was specific for these neomorphic molecules and
something that we could not achieve with either BTB domain inhibition or also
degradation of BCL6.
So with that, I want to conclude. I hope I could convince you that targeted protein
degradation is really a powerful loss of function modality that is based on
reprogramming or rewiring E3 ligases.
I think we're hopeful as a community that it will allow us to continue to
expand the tractable target space in the human proteome.
And I think it will benefit from really rational strategies for molecular glue
discovery and design moving forward.
As a community, I think we should also think beyond loss of function
approaches. At least I'm incredibly excited about it.
And there was also a brilliant induced proximity lecture
yesterday chaired by Michael Erb, and I think there's a lot of momentum in that
space.
I've shared with you vignettes that speak to how we can rewire
sumoylation networks to induce repressive
dominant signal, which could go beyond loss of function.
And on the other hand, I've shared with you data of how we can directly rewire
repressive targets by recruiting the BAF complex.
And I think really the rate-limiting step in the field here is our
imagination and our creativity. And there's obviously many more biological
processes that can be reprogrammed and rewired with small molecules.
And we believe that proximity induction is the general framework to
make this work.
I want to conclude by thanking people in the lab that did the work.
So the SIRD work was done by Matthias and Carolina, the BAF
work by Lisa and Dmitry. And I thank all of our wonderful
collaboration partners and funding sources, and you for your attention.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Winter.
Our next speaker is Dr. Regina Barzilay. Dr.
Barzilay is the School of Engineering Distinguished Professor for
AI and Health and the AI faculty lead at the Jameel
Clinic of the Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
She's a computer scientist whose research has focused on natural language
processing and applications of deep learning to
chemistry and oncology. Her laboratory is
currently developing machine learning methods to understand
how proteins and small molecules interact with one another,
to model and design novel biomolecules, and to
enhance clinical care from pre-diagnosis to
post-treatment. We look forward to hearing more about her work during her
presentation titled, "Rethinking Cancer Diagnosis and
Treatment with AI from Molecular Mechanisms to
Clinical Management." Please welcome Dr. Barzilay.
Thank you. Thank you very much for the introduction and for having me
over. So before we go to talk about AI, I just
want to start by looking how we today analyze patients'
data. And here I'm showing you a table that come
from New England Journal of Medicine, where
this trial looked at the benefits of,
I think, of ovarian suppression for premenopausal
breast cancer women. And what you can see here, at first,
we see the survival curves, and we also see peer
group analysis. Looking at this data, it's really
hard to see who is going to benefit from this
therapy. And it was my first New England Journal of Medicine paper that I
read in my life. I was one of those patients that really couldn't make much sense
of it. And,
this is a trial that involved thousands of women, and we
couldn't understand much who would really benefit from the therapy.
Now, on the other hand of the spectrum, are papers that really try
to understand the mechanism. And I'm showing one of my favorite papers,
TracerX. In order to understand cancer biology and to get some
new insights, we need to have data in a very
different level of complexity. We need spatial transcriptomics, single-cell
data, and so on. None of this data is collected in routine
clinical care due to cost and scalability issues.
So one question that I'm thinking about
where AI can really make a big difference is whether we can
extract biological insights directly from the data that
is collected in routine clinical care.
And I will show you a few tools that exactly try to achieve these
goals. And first, I will start with the tools that looks
at the pathology slides. Why pathology?
First of all, we collect it every day, in every cancer
diagnostics. But the second reason is that
already we have lots of papers that demonstrated excellent results
in applying AI to diagnosing automatically,
from the slides, the patient, but not only that, but predicting all
the different outcomes like risk of progression and so on.
So it's really a powerful modality.
The only problem is that even though this model can predict you the outcomes,
they cannot really explain to you what is the biological
mechanism of action.
What we would ideally want to see is the models that can
zoom in a particular molecular programs that can
explain to you the response. For instance, I'm showing examples of one of
such programs, angiogenesis, that took a
lot of research to connect this program to a particular
outcomes. Can we fully automate it?
Can the machine take the pathology slides and
identify this type of program? Now, you can say for
this program, we can do it because it's very visual.
It involves blood vessels, so it should be able to predict it.
But if we are looking at other
molecular pathways, it may be very hard to do.
So what we actually have done, we developed this new model, which is called
SPARK, which can take a pathology slide and not only predict
the outcome, but it can also identify all
the molecular pathways that are involved in this particular
development. So in this case, I'm showing you a pathology
slide, I think it's from colon cancer, and it shows all the
top
programs that were involved in this particular response.
And the color demonstrates you for every patch on the slide how much a
specific program is active.
Now, how we can learn it automatically?
Luckily, today, we have a number of dataset where we have pathology
slides together with a spatial transcriptomics, which enable us
to go for every patch in the slide and see exactly which one
of the programs are active on the patch in the slide.
This data can be used for training deep learning models so that
now the model can take a slide and predict for you which
ones of the programs are active on the slide.
So in a sense now each patch is annotated with 40 numbers that
correspond to all the different molecular programs.
And you can see on the slide hopefully, the
names of these different programs that we're extracting.
As you can see, the accuracy is pretty high.
AUC is 90, the Pearson is
74. So it actually shows that you can robustly
already extract these molecular pathways.
And next, what you can do, you can take a normal pathology slide
and extract from it the pathways, also to
encode all the visual features of the slide to train
neural model to predict a variety of long-term
outcomes like disease-free survival, response to treatment, and so on,
depending on what you're trying to learn.
So two points about this model. First of all, it enables you
to jointly both look at the molecular pathways and
the imaging features. And the second important point that is responsible
for actually high accuracy of this model is the fact that the
model can look at
not only at the presence of molecular pathway, but it actually can
look how these different programs appear together.
So looking at the colocalization is actually an important information
that the model can learn from. So adding this molecular
information really helps in prediction of outcomes.
I'm showing to you multiple different prediction
tasks. So in gray, you can see a model that just looks at
the image of the slide. On orange, we are
looking at the model that both looks at the image itself and the molecular
programs. You can see across all of them, there is a benefit of
adding this information. But maybe more importantly, as I said, that it
can actually allows you to understand what molecular programs
contribute to the response. I am showing to you an ovarian cancer
cohort and-Here, just to make
it more visually clear, I grouped the programs
based on their function. You can see there are
proliferative programs in the blue color
and immuno-stromal one in red color.
You can see that respondents and non-responders in terms of the molecular
pathways look very different. Now, what this
model enables us to do. The first one, it can better stratify the
patient and predict the outcomes, but it also can give us an
idea what should be our next target for the
intervention. Really using this data to identify
targets, I think is the main application of this technology.
And I am happy to say that we developed SPARK, this
model, SPARK, as part of the ADAPT trial.
This is ARPA-H program that aims to find the best
treatment for metastatic patients.
And,
here you can see the team of all the clinicians and researchers that
are involved in this big effort, and SPARK is going to be actually
helping to match patients to their treatment.
Now, I want to kind of switch gears, and this
part of the talk will be closer to the material that
Dr. Winter presented, and I'm going to start talking about molecular
modeling.
So again,
many of you are familiar with AlphaFold.
We developed at MIT, in my group, the tool called BOLZ.
So what these tools do, they take the sequence of the protein,
the small molecule, and create for you the 3D
pose, how the small molecule and protein interact.
It's not only limited to this biomolecular, they can actually take any
type of biomolecules together. And,
BOLZ performs comparable in terms of accuracy to AlphaFold
3, but the big advantage, it's fully open.
The training code is open, so if you want to fine-tune it on a
particular class of molecules, you can do it with BOLZ.
You cannot do it with AlphaFold 3. And another big advantage
of
BOLZ is that it also provides you binding affinity.
So you can now compute the binding affinity between protein and small molecule.
So I don't know. I cannot see you guys here. There are many of you.
I know there are loads and loads based on the downloads of people who are using
BOLZ. But before I came here, I was trying to find
a way how it can be used in other application besides drug
discovery, because we developed it for drug discovery. So let me show you some.
So,
the first one actually comes from a clinical collaborator, Dr.
Gainor from MGH, and he described a
concrete problem that he faces as a thoracic oncologist.
So today, there are luckily multiple small molecule for
EGFR mutation. And the question is, which one of these
molecules to select when you have a particular
mutant? And, he pointed me to this paper that I
think was published a few years back in "Nature," that actually
shows that the efficacy of a particular
drug depends to the structural features of the
interaction of the specific EGFR mutation and the small
molecule, because different drugs actually bind to different pockets.
And they demonstrated in this paper, that if you can produce the
structure and analyze the interaction, you can predict efficacy.
Now, the problem with this particular paper was that it actually
required to do crystallography and other things that you cannot do in routine
clinical care.
However, we've demonstrated that if you just do exactly the same
without doing crystallography, just running BOLZ, you're going to take the
mutant, and you're going to take the small molecule and run
BOLZ. BOLZ give you a probability, which gives you a binding
score. And you can use this binding score as a
metric of the match. And, what we've demonstrated
reproducing the results in the paper, that using this fully automatic
computation, you can discriminate between responders and
non-responders, both on cell lines and on the patient data.
We used Hartwig data for this one. Another example of
how you can use BOLZ is predicting off-target interaction.
We
know that our targeted drug have multiple other interaction
beyond the intended target, and here I'm citing a paper that
actually quantified, looking at around 200 drugs
and 200 proteins, trying to see the
interactions.
Because this kind of discovery happened to be using
wet lab experiments, you cannot really easily extract it
to the full
set of human proteins. Again, luckily, you can just take BOLZ,
take your molecule, try it,
run it across all the protein candidates that you're thinking about,
and rank them based on how strongly they're likely to interact
with the small molecule. And what we've demonstrated that by
using this rank, you can identify promising
interaction, and here we show that if you just look at one
set of top ranks protein, you can identify
80% of binders. Again, the idea here is not to
eliminate
experiments. It just push your experiments to the most
promising part of the space.
Another yet example where we took
the structure model and applied successfully is
TCR-pMHC binding. This is a work done as a part
of Matchmakers.
This is our grand challenge
proposed project. So in this case, people
for a while were trying to solve TCR-pMHC problem,
looking at the sequence data, and the results were
notVery promising. So what we've done, we again,
just took the structure model, run it on TCR PMHC,
and we can already see significant boost.
But the point is that you're not even training.
I am showing you the result when you just take the model and apply it out of
the box, and you already see some promising beginning.
And of course, much more needs to be done.
But what you've seen in this and other applications, that
this structure model, which are not fine-tuned, which is just taken out of the
box, already can deliver important and
informative insights into our data.
So now, again, because Dr. Winter talked just before me, I
decided to share with you a relatively new tool that we
released last November. It's called Bolgen.
And what Bolgen can do is to generate
binders, and it can generate binders in any modality to
target in any modality. So here you can, for instance, see
telomerase and
Bolgen life generates you a peptide
binder for this target.
Now I know that some of you at least are familiar with other
models that you can use for binder generation.
I just want to highlight two important features of
Bolgen. First one, again, it generalizes across
modalities, and the second one, we really want to be
able to generalize to a new target space.
We don't want to stay what we already know and just generate more of the
same. We've demonstrated that Bolgen can actually go to a new
undruggable space and produce binders.
And here you can see some of the binders that Bolgen
generated that we already empirically validated.
I should say not we, but our collaborators empirically
validated. And you can see a wide range of modalities
in which they were generated. And I think it's just the beginning.
There are lots and lots of things that could be done, and I
would be excited if some of you can try this tool.
So what I've presented so far very much relates
to kind of futuristic things, not the things that we can take it
and bring tomorrow to the patient.
So in the second part of my talk, I would like to talk
about the technologies that already exist and ready to be translated.
And here I want to talk about the topic of great importance,
which is
risk stratification and
early detection. So what I'm showing you here on the slide is
the statistics related to breast cancer diagnosis.
So as you can see on the slide, and it comes from SEERS, that
almost one third of the patients today who are diagnosed
with breast cancer are diagnosed beyond
localized stage. And as you can see again on the statistics, these
patients typically have worse prognosis than those that are
diagnosed earlier.
Now, you can be thinking and saying, we're already screening women
regularly. What can we do? How we can change the statistics?
And I want to say there are lots that we can do.
It's true that we are screening women regularly, but the question is
whether our reading of their mammograms really gives you a lot of
insight, and there where AI can step in.
And just to convince you, I'm going to show you my own mammograms.
I was diagnosed with breast cancer in 2014, but if you're
looking at previous mammograms that we're going to blow it out,
you can see that at least two years prior, there was something growing
on in the tissue. We don't know what it was.
And you can say maybe you were unlucky, and
it's very unique stories that happened to you.
So here I'm citing a paper
that was not done by AI people, but it was done by radiologists that
demonstrates that it's by no means unique
story. Here they're looking at a very special cohort.
Those are high-risk women that are BRCA patients who are
screened in a high-risk program and screened with
MRI. And what they demonstrate in the paper, for 31% of
these women, cancer was already seen a year prior that was
missed. Again, this is a high-risk cohort with MRI.
You can imagine how the statistics look for general population.
So with this idea, we developed a model which is called Mirai.
Mirai means future in Japanese. So what this model does, it can look at the
image and predict what's going to happen to this
patient in the next five years.
And it's a model you can see the publication is like, I think the first publication
is since 2018. It's quite old by now.
Now you can say how the model can detect something about the future that
radiologists cannot really see, because we are asking the model to do
something which radiologists cannot do, really predict the future.
As we all know that cancer doesn't grow from today to tomorrow.
It's typically a very long process that requires multiple
changes in the tissue. These changes are very subtle, so it's very
hard for the human eye to detect it.
But the machine, which is trained on the right data, can actually
detect these very subtle signs. How do we train the
machine? We're taking images and
looking at
what happened to this patient in the next five years.
So if you're going to look at women who are diagnosed, who had their mammogram in
2020, you can see what is their outcome in the next five
years. And the machine correlates these changes in the image in the
tissue with an outcome. How well does it work?
So here I am using c-index because it's a standard measure.
It's a five-year c-index.So the model that I just
briefly described you, called Mirai, is shown in yellow.
I am taking the numbers from Science Translation paper.
It's 0.8. Now let's look at others.
We always need to compare, correct?
So here you can see in green, TeraQSIC.
TeraQSIC is a model that kind of asks all these questions like what
is your BMI?
Do you have family cancer? And all these kind of questionnaires, puts them
together with a statistical model and gives you the risk.
The
C-index here is 0.63. Today, in the United States,
with this model, you can get chemo prevention, you will get MRI.
Now, to make it even funnier, look at the density, which is a federally mandated
biomarker, 0.5. 0.5 C-index is
random.
And we will go and talk more about the density, but at least what you can see that,
again, AI model can actually see much better than what we are currently
using
in patient care. Now,
I know that for some reason, C-index is not the measure that people in this
community love. So I want to translate it into something that's
more relatable and compare the risk as predicted by Mirai
to other risk populations. So what we've done, Mirai gives you a
score, and you can determine that your high risk patient
are top 2% based on Mirai. And I'm going to now
be comparing them against BRCA patients.
So there is this paper from JAMA that quantified average breast
cancer risk for BRCA1 and BRCA2 patient for one
year and four years. So for now, just look at the black
boxes. You can see that, for instance, for BRCA1, one year
average risk is 2.18.
If you look at the equivalent number for Mirai, it's almost three
times small.
If you're looking for four years, again, BRCA1, it's like,
I cannot quite see it. Let me see here.
It's 6.35. If you're looking at Mirai,
it's 18
something. So we can clearly see that this patient that Mirai
identify high risk really are patients that we need to be
paying attention. Nobody in this audience would say, let just BRCA patient
be. Today, these patients are latent patient, patients like me that we
don't know that we are at risk, and our doctors don't know that we are at
risk. So this is just a comparison.
Now, I shall say that Mirai was very extensively tested.
We made the code for Mirai publicly available.
Any of you can download it and try it.
It was tested by many researchers and clinicians around the world.
I think that one of the, at least what I know, and it was published, it's around
2.2 million mammograms. Another exciting thing that
happened recently is that now this model is actually is part of
prospective clinical trials. You can see two trials
that happen in the US that actually send high risk patient,
one in Massachusetts at UMass, another one at UCSF.
When we're looking whether the high risk patients, as identified by
Mirai, can be sent to MRI.
There is an ongoing trial in Israel, where the breast cancer screening starts
at 50. The idea of this trial is to take younger women at age
40, give them one mammogram, and decides who needs to come
back at 50, which are low risk, and the rest will have their
personalized screening regime. I am also very excited to say
that now Mirai is going to be part of the large European
trial, MiPEBS, which compares risk
stratified screening versus standard age-based
screening. So we are already accumulating data from multiple
prospective trials that look at the value
of this technology.
Now, hopefully the movie works. So I will tell you what it is.
So Mirai, by now, is quite old.
You may ask, what is generative AI?
So here is a piece of generative AI, and this is our new
model called MamaGen. What it does, it takes your breast, in this
case it's my breast, takes the breast and generates how
this breast is likely to look in a year.
So let's see if the movie works.
Let's see.
So here you see my breast prior to diagnosis, and
then you can see, with the green subtitle, this
is a generated next image, and the purple one
is a true one. So you can see that looking at my prior image, the
model can generate full breast and even identify the cancer
and the size
of the mass that will be detected. So if you
try to see how does it work, think about all these program that do
aging, correct? You can put your face, and if you're brave enough to see how you're
going to look in 10 years. So here we develop similar model for
mammograms. And again, how it can help us practically, it can
help us because it can tell us how aggressive likely the cancer
is going to be. Mirai is not trying to answer this question.
Okay. Now, after we talk about all this amazing stuff from the future, let's go
back to our reality. So our reality today, majority of women in
the United States learn about their risk by getting a
letter from their provider when they do mammogram.
In 2023, there is a new federal law that requires the provider,
if you have a dense breast, to tell you that you are in increased
risk of breast cancer. 45% of American
women have dense breasts. 45% get this letter.
Now,
you can say, "You did just one study with C-index 50%.
Maybe there is some other study where this number is going to be high."So
I recently,
myself and my collaborators of course, collected a very large data
set of 1.3 million exams from multiple hospitals,
where we actually knew their outcomes.
And we compare a measure, which is most standardly used in
this literature, which is called relative risk.
Again, if it is one, it means no effect.
So if you look at the red one, this is a density, you can see
that it's 1.2. So somebody may be arguing and saying, "If it is
1.2, maybe it's still worth to send the letter because it's not one." There is some
tiny
increase in relative risk. However, what you see here in
gray is relative risk if you happen to
be above age 70. Nobody in their right mind is going
to send the letters to every woman about age 70 saying that she's in
increased risk of breast cancer, but in fact, the relative risk, 2.1,
is higher than the binary density
classifications that currently has to be done based on the federal law.
Now, if you look historically and say, "Where density come from?"
Today, people who are studying in medical school are learning about density, where
does it come from? So in 1967, Dr. Wolfe was a
radiologist who kind of asked a very reasonable question.
The question that he asked, "If I look at mammograms of women who later
develop breast cancer, what is so special about it?" And he
identified several patterns saying, that they correlate
with the future of breast cancer. The interesting part, if you can read it,
he actually say that he used a computer to do this assessment.
But nevertheless, he identified these categories,
which later American College of Radiology coded into the
density classes. In 2023, it
actually became a federal law to notify patients about the
increased risk. So the question to you and to all of us, how
long it will take to take this high-powered AI model that
really have a capacity to see the future and bring
them to provide a very precise definition
of risk? And I want to finish my talk on a
high note and say about some really great news.
The balloons are coming. So, just this
April, NCCN changed the guidelines, and
now the image-based model, like Mirai, can be used for
identifying high-risk patients.
This change in the guidelines was based on this meta review that I'm
showing to you, which combined the results from multiple
studies. Many of them come from Mirai, from our model, that
show that this model consistently outperform
everything that currently is used in clinical practice.
But this is just one first step towards bringing
this technology to patients. Loads and loads has to be done, and
we should really part away from density and use the technology of
21st century. So, with that, I just wanted to
thank all my students and my collaborators,
and of course, our funding agencies that enable
this research. And thank you for listening to me. Thank you.
Well, thank you, Dr. Barzilay. And we thank all of our speakers this morning for
their exceptional presentations, showcasing the cutting edge of cancer
science and medicine.
And thank you to all of you for attending this opening plenary
session. We're grateful for your attention, and we hope you'll enjoy the rest of
the meeting.
Thank you.